this is a Chinese alligator native to  eastern China it is so rare that there  are only a hundred and thirty left in  the wild  known as the Yangtze alligator it is one  of the smallest crocodilians in the  world their stocky body is covered in  hard scales on the back and it's blunt  teeth are perfect for crushing shelled  animals like clams and snails their menu  also includes fish insects birds and the  occasional small mammal they stay in  subtropical areas with fresh water  sources like lakes ponds marshes and  streams sadly these habitats are  disappearing often to make room for  agriculture this and perching are the  biggest threats to the survival of the  species  luckily they do well in captivity as  they have been successfully bred in  wildlife refuges and zoos this is the  Chinese alligator